salle bondée ambiance décontractée et
des plats qui donnent l'eau à la bouche
la chef propriétaire caroline dumas
tente d'absorber ces coûts croissants
mais la facture est de plus en plus
salées ça avant la pandémie c'est 14 de
l'or est maintenant génial cet énorme
enjeu devrait pas vendre
[Rires]
[Musique]
la note au restaurant va bondir en
moyenne de 7,8 pour cent au pays en 2022
selon le rapport de restaurants canada
pour joindre les deux bouts plus du
tiers des salles à manger quand même
monter les prix de 10 à 15% enfin c'est
quand même une hausse consistant on
sors pas mal quand même ici et
je pense que personnellement oui ça fera
peut-être moins de restaurants le
principal responsable si le prix des
aliments qui a augmenté de près de 10%
en juillet par rapport à l'année
dernière regarde se voit ici j'ai des
noix qui normalement
juste avant la pandémie c'est 13 99 puis
c'était fascinant parce que je le vois
au mans testeront 10,99 qu'elle est
maintenant aujourd'hui ses 18,4
nos fournisseurs leurs augmentations
sont encore plus élevés que ça on
s'attendait même à une hausse à être
obligé de hausser les prix un peu plus
haut que cela c'est sans parler des
salaires croissance dans un secteur où
il manque plus de 170 mille travailleurs
[Musique]
dans ce restaurant rapide grecque maria
boutinot sait très bien que sa clientèle
cherche les petits prix les siens ne
suivent pas l'augmentation du coût de
lui la friture notamment et on n'a pas
le choix d'augmenter un petit peu mais
on veut pas augmenter trop sinon la
clientèle
c'est un problème actuellement un
restaurant moyen fait une marche à une
marge bénéficiaire d'environ 2 à 3%
uniquement donc vous comprenez que pour
nous c'est très très difficile d'arriver
actuellement
comme d'autres elle absorbe une partie
de la facture pour demeurer compétitive
en attendant que la surchauffe
économique se calme un peu ici jean
phlippe use radio canada montréal